Dans sa lettre au Galate, l'apôtre Paul, il est en train de faire face à un problème assez grave.
Donc c'était l'une des premières églises qu'il avait implantées.
C'était une église qui a eu un commencement vraiment très beau.
C'était une église formée par une majorité des païens, des personnes qui n'avaient pas un arrière-plan juif,
qui ne connaissaient pas tous les détails de la loi juif, qui n'avaient pas pour base de leur relation avec Dieu,
les lois de l'Ancien Testament, la connaissance des cérémonies de l'Ancien Testament,
mais qui ont été présentées à Jésus-Christ et Jésus-Christ se crucifie.
Cela a été suffisant.
Leur conversion authentique a été scellée de manière très évidente par la visitation de son esprit.
Ils ont commencé une très belle course.
Sans avoir un arrière-plan juif, ils ont pu expérimenter des transformations des vies tellement puissantes
qu'ils sont devenus beaucoup plus pieux que les plus ailés des pharisiens, des religieux.
Et donc, même si leur style de vie n'était pas marqué par la loi des juifs, leur vie a été tellement transformée.
Et naturellement, ils ont commencé à vivre une vie très similaire à la vie de Jésus-Christ.
Car l'esprit du Christ est passé à habiter chez eux et les caractères du Christ ont été manifestés dans leur vie.
Ça, c'était le début de leur foi.
Par contre, un courant d'entre les juifs convertis, les judaïsants, qui reconnaissaient que Christ était véritablement les Messies,
mais qui avait une très mauvaise compréhension de comment la vie chrétienne est maintenue
et comment nous progressons dans la vie chrétienne.
Donc, habitués à leur culture religieuse juive et encore habitués à une notion erronée d'un privilège ethnique
que les juifs pourraient avoir.
Car quand on comparait dans l'extérieur ou dans la surface les comportements religieux des juifs
avec les nations païennes, avec même leur idolâtrie qui parfois légitimaient la promiscuité, par exemple, l'immoralité.
Et donc, c'est clair qu'en regardant dans la surface, dans l'extérieur,
on avait plutôt l'impression que les juifs étaient plus moralistes.
Ils n'étaient pas si corrompus dans l'apparence de la surface que les nations païennes.
Par contre, il s'agissait d'une grande hypocrisie dans la plupart des cas.
Malgré leur religion, ils pensaient que leur justice était conquise par leurs propres efforts religieux.
Et ils regardaient les autres comme étant quelque part encore plus loin des dieux qu'eux-mêmes.
Ils se sentaient très privilégiés.
Donc, même après une possible conversion ou la reconnaissance au moment où Christ était le Messie,
les judaïsants croyaient que la seule manière de vivre la vraie vie chrétienne
était de revenir et de se conformer aux pratiques religieuses juives.
Garder certaines dates, baser la relation avec Dieu.
Ok, pour mon salut, c'était Christ, les besoins.
Mais après mon salut, j'ai besoin plutôt de transpirer pour ne pas perdre mon salut
et pour progresser dans la foi.
Et donc, leur base de relation avec Dieu, même après la conversion, est redevenue la base de la performance.
Et toujours avec l'idée d'un Dieu contre eux.
Ils sont arrivés chez les Galates et ils ont contaminé cette église.
Et les Galates eux-mêmes, malgré le fait qu'ils avaient connu véritablement beaucoup de progrès,
une transformation réelle, une notion de filiation divine étant adotée en Christ en tant qu'enfant des dieux.
Ils avaient déjà expérimenté la vraie liberté, celle qui nous pousse envers la sanctification.
Mais maintenant, ils étaient terrifiés par ces menaces de la loi qui étaient restaurées.
Et donc, ils ont presque perdu la réjouissance.
Ils n'ont pas, attention, ils n'ont pas perdu leur statut d'enfant.
Mais ils ont perdu leur réjouissance de la vie chrétienne.
Ils ont perdu leur liberté.
Ils étaient à point même de se faire circoncire, de s'adapter aux pratiques religieuses des juifs.
Et donc, l'apôtre Paul, il est vraiment très préoccupé.
C'est l'une des lettres où il sera les plus, on va dire, c'est la lettre où Paul, il va faire les moins des recommandations, des loges au début de la lettre.
C'est une lettre où il commence très tôt, très vite à frapper très fermement les Galates.
Car il est étonné qu'en ayant expérimenté la vraie liberté en Christ, indépendamment de la connaissance de la loi,
ces hommes, ils étaient déjà beaucoup plus en conformité avec la loi, rien que par l'action de son esprit dans leur vie.
Et maintenant, ils étaient en train d'abandonner leur liberté, abandonner l'expérience et la réjouissance de leur filiation.
Et donc, l'apôtre Paul, il va faire des corrections, d'abord doctrinaires, en disant,
si vous croyez que vous maintenez votre salut ou que vous ne voulez pas perdre votre salut par vos performances,
cela veut dire qu'il y a quelque part la possibilité en vous de vous sauver complètement.
Et si vous auriez la capacité ou la possibilité de vous sauver par vous-même,
Dieu n'allait jamais envoyer Christ à la croix.
C'est un mépris envers Christ.
Et si vous pensez que vous pouvez perdre votre salut,
c'est comme si vous étiez en train de suggérer que ce qui Christ a souffert à la croix,
ou l'obéissance parfaite que Christ a pourvue dans sa chair,
n'était pas suffisante, n'était pas efficace.
C'est comme si Christ n'avait pas souffert suffisamment.
Et donc, Paul va corriger, et la doctrine principale, c'est la doctrine de la justification par la foi,
c'est-à-dire, les débuts de la foi, c'est une déclaration légale de la part des dieux,
car par la foi, nous nous associons à Christ dans sa vie parfaite et dans sa mort.
Et étant associé à Christ, Dieu, en tant qu'éjuge, il peut déclarer,
vous êtes complètement absus sur la base de l'obéissance parfaite du Christ
et sur la base de la punition du Christ à votre place.
Et donc, comme Christ a vécu l'année parfaite à votre place et qu'il est mort à votre place,
d'une fois pour toutes, étant associé à Christ,
il n'y a rien qui manque en termes de dette envers Dieu.
Vous êtes adopté sur une base des justices parfaites.
Dieu peut vous traiter en tant qu'enfant librement, d'une fois pour toutes,
car il a traité d'une fois pour toutes avec Christ comme s'il était les coupables qui vous étiez.
OK ?
Et donc, c'est un changement des positions définitives et pour toujours.
Sauf que, dans les vies où ces changements des positions sont vrais,
dans les vies où ces changements des positions ont compté avec la vraie foi,
la vraie répentance et la vraie foi,
ces changements n'est pas tout simplement un changement des positions légales.
C'est un changement de nature.
car l'intérêt des dieux à envoyer Christ à la croix n'était pas tout simplement des pourvoirs,
des parts non parfaites,
c'était de faire de nous ces enfants.
Donc, ceux qui sont associés véritablement à Christ par la foi,
ce sont ceux qui sont associés à Christ de manière vitale.
C'est l'esprit du Christ qui vient habiter en nous pour nous encherter,
ou pour nous, en français,
pour nous greffer à la vigne qu'est Jésus-Christ.
Donc, nous, des branches qui étaient morts,
sont greffées à Christ et on gagne la vie.
Et donc, ceux qui sont associés par la foi à Jésus-Christ,
ils ne sont pas qu'éclarés juste devant Dieu,
ils sont rendus justes progressivement,
ils sont sanctifiés.
Donc, la conception de l'apôtre Paul des justifications par la foi,
elle ne s'arrête pas avec cette déclaration légale.
Cette conviction que nous pouvons avoir d'une fois pour toutes
que si nous sommes réconciliés avec Dieu par la foi à Jésus-Christ,
nous ne pouvons plus jamais être traités par Dieu
comme autre chose qu'enfant parfait.
Ok ?
Car nous sommes en Jésus-Christ.
Par contre, nous ne pouvons jamais reposer et croire
que nous sommes réconciliés avec Dieu par Jésus-Christ
si dans notre vie pratique, nous ne voyons pas des transformations.
En ayant corrigé cette mauvaise doctrine,
cette influence des judaïsants,
l'apôtre Paul, il va apporter la notion pratique.
Et dans la notion pratique, c'est comme si Paul était en train de dire
« Je suis plutôt convaincu de votre conversion authentique. »
Dernièrement, à cause de cette division dans cette église,
vous êtes en train de vous remordre et vous dévorer.
Vous êtes plutôt en train de manifester plus les restes de la chair qui est en vous
qui est les fruits de l'esprit.
Mais c'est comme si l'apôtre Paul était en train de dire
« Soyez ce que vous êtes.
Vivez en conformité, en cohérence avec votre nouvelle nature. »
Ce qui est important à remarquer ici, c'est que
lorsque l'apôtre Paul va porter cet enseignement
à propos de la liberté chrétienne,
cette liberté pour laquelle Christ nous a affranchis,
c'est une liberté qui n'est pas tout simplement un changement de position légale.
On n'est pas que délivré de la condamnation de l'enfer,
on est délivré de l'esclavage de la chair,
de la pollution du péché.
Et la vraie liberté, c'est de marcher progressivement
dans la direction du but de notre existence.
Vivre une vie d'amour.
Vivre la vie d'amour que Dieu nous a créée pour vivre.
Restaurer l'image de Dieu en nous.
Faire que nous vivons une vie comme celle du Christ.
Donc les fruits de l'esprit sont quelque part les chrétiens.
Les fruits de l'esprit sont un petit Christ.
C'est l'esprit du Christ qui habite en nous
et qui produit en nous une vie
qui est la vie de notre Père céleste.
Qui est la vie de l'enfant parfait.
Donc c'est très intéressant car dans cette dynamique des corrections,
l'apôtre Paul n'est pas en train de dire aux Galactes,
vous avez donc perdu votre salut,
réveillé au début de la course.
Il n'est pas en train de dire,
maintenant il faut que vous faites des pénitences
pour compenser tous les maux que vous avez faits.
La seule chose que l'apôtre Paul a dit,
c'est qu'il ne reste aucune condamnation sur le camp vrai enfant des dieux.
La seule chose qui s'est attendue de vous,
c'est que vous soyez ce que vous êtes.
Donc Paul n'est pas ici dans une dynamique de faire pour corriger nos erreurs.
Paul, il est ici dans une dynamique d'exhortation
pour manifester notre nouvelle nature.
Donc Paul, il est plus dans la direction des lettres,
d'un indicatif, d'une description de ce qui nous sommes,
car c'est ce que les chrétiens manquent le plus, je crois,
quand on pense à comprendre ce qu'est le phénomène de la conversion
et ce qui est la progression en sanctification,
car ce qui va frustrer le plus les chrétiens,
c'est de penser à la sanctification dans la dynamique de faire
au lieu de penser à la sanctification dans la dynamique de l'être.
C'est cette communion intime avec le Saint-Esprit
qui produit et qui manifeste la progression en sanctification.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer,
car lorsqu'il présente les œuvres de la chair
et qu'il dit,
ceux qui vivent dans la pratique de telles choses
ne peuvent pas hériter les règles de Dieu,
c'est intéressant car ils nous protègent déjà des mauvaises conclusions.
Car on pourrait penser,
si je ne pratique pas ces choses,
je vais conquérir les règles des cieux.
Non, ils n'hériteront pas.
C'est-à-dire, même s'il est en train de parler des œuvres de la chair,
ce sont des choses que nous pouvons produire de nous-mêmes,
mais qui nous empêchent d'hériter
si nous vivons dans la pratique de ces choses.
Si nous sommes esclaves de ces pratiques,
c'est un indice que nous ne sommes pas hérétiques,
que nous ne sommes pas enfants de Dieu.
Par contre, si nous sommes devenus enfants de Dieu,
attention, la Bible, elle est hyper pessimiste
par rapport à la capacité de l'homme naturel
de choisir pour Dieu ou de conquérir son salut.
Là, quand on regarde les œuvres de la chair,
c'est-à-dire, c'est dans la direction dans laquelle nous allons
si une opération miraculeuse ne change pas notre nature.
Et donc, les œuvres de la chair,
c'est pour décrire l'état de l'homme
qui n'est pas converti,
qui n'est pas né de nouveau,
qui n'est pas enfant de Dieu.
Par contre,
les œuvres de la chair ne sont pas confrontées
aux œuvres que nous pouvons faire avec l'esprit.
«œuvre de la chair », c'est effort personnel.
Par contre, « fruit de l'esprit »,
ce n'est pas forcément quelque chose
qui s'est à nous de faire.
C'est l'identification
d'une œuvre qui nous a touchés,
dont l'origine, elle est Saint-Esprit
et qui produit en nous
ces nouveaux caractères,
ces vertus, ces fruits,
un fruit sanglier.
Donc, la Bible, elle est aussi très optimiste
par rapport à ce que nous sommes
en Jésus-Christ.
Remarquez bien,
là où les Saint-Esprits sont en train d'agir,
si vous voulez être sûrs
que les Saint-Esprits sont en train d'agir,
Paul n'est pas en train de nous donner
une liste de dons.
Il nous encourage à chercher tous les dons,
mais quand il écrit au Corinthien,
il fait énormément de remarques
envers des personnes qui pratiquaient les dons
en complète dissonance
avec l'action du Saint-Esprit.
Des dons spirituels,
pratiqués de manière à nier le Saint-Esprit.
Pourquoi ?
Car ils étaient en train de pratiquer ces dons
avec beaucoup de vain gloire,
avec beaucoup de disputes entre eux.
C'est-à-dire, ils étaient en train de faire
en mauvais osage des dons qu'ils ont reçus.
Mais les indices
d'un réveil
d'une nouvelle naissance
ne sont pas trouvés si tant
dans les dons fonctionnels
que nous pouvons avoir pour faire
l'Église s'édifier,
et c'est plutôt dans ces caractères du Christ
qu'il est Saint-Esprit en train de former en nous.
Donc, si vous voulez
trouver un lieu
où un réveil est en train de se passer,
nous devrions chercher,
indépendamment de la manière
dont les personnes sont en train de réagir
au message de l'Évangile,
s'ils sont en train de sauter
ou tomber par terre,
c'est d'accompagner les vies de ces personnes
dans tous les jours
et de se demander
est-ce que c'est une personne
remplie d'amour,
de paix,
de douceur,
de patience,
de joie,
ou si
ces moments
dans la semaine
où je vois
son comportement
spectaculaire
s'arrêtent ici
et que sa vie
est en complète dissonance
avec cette constance
qu'il devrait présenter
par l'effet.
Donc, l'identité du chrétien
est la solution
de l'apôtre Paul
pour les problèmes
de cette Église
dans Galatie.
Mais c'est aussi
une occasion
qui a donné
à l'apôtre Paul
les privilèges
de porter un enseignement
très riche
envers
l'expérience
des conversions
et des sanctifications
de nous tous.
Car même si nous ne sommes pas
en train de vivre
les mêmes problématiques
des Galates,
les mêmes dangers
et les mêmes dynamiques
sont toujours en train
de se porter
envers nos vies.
Et donc,
la question
qu'il veut
pour nous tous,
c'est de nous demander
si nous avons
les fruits
de l'esprit
dans nos vies.
Si nous avons déjà
expérimenté
d'une manière radicale
au moment de notre conversion
et si c'est vrai
pour nous,
nous devons résoudre,
nous devons
être résolus
dans la dynamique
de manifester
ces fruits.
Car si nous avons
expérimenté
la vraie conversion,
les saints esprits
qui habitent
dans tous les chrétiens,
dans chaque chrétien,
et à partir de là,
nous devons faire
très peu d'efforts
quelque part
pour manifester
ces choses.
C'est presque un choix
quelque part
de tout simplement
manifester ça
au lieu de céder
aux tentations
de la chair.
Et donc,
l'apôtre Paul,
en ayant parlé
des œuvres
de la chair,
il va bien sûr
les contraster
avec les fruits
sanguliers
où là où il apparaît,
il apparaît toujours
en harmonie parfaite
avec toutes
ses autres vertus.
Voilà pourquoi
l'intérelation
entre chacun
de ces vertus
est une intérelation
très importante.
C'est impossible
de considérer
que nous sommes
les fruits de l'esprit
ou nous manifestons
ou nous avons
les fruits de l'esprit
si nous avons
juste quelques-uns
de ces éléments
et pas les autres.
Car ils sont
nécessairement liés
comme nous sommes
en train de voir.
Et donc,
la relation entre eux,
on a déjà commencé
à traiter.
Donc,
on voit
comment ces premiers
trois éléments
sont très importants.
Donc,
on voit
l'amour,
la joie
et la paix
qui sont plutôt
l'état d'esprit
si on veut dire
comme ça.
C'est la condition
de l'âme
qui a traversé
une expérience
légitime
des conversions.
C'est-à-dire
les sommets
de la satisfaction
humaine
la carence
la plus fondamentale
c'est d'être
aimé
dans l'amour
parfait.
Et en Dieu,
dans l'évangile,
nous trouvons
l'expression
la plus sublime,
la plus élevée
d'amour.
C'est Dieu lui-même
qui est amour
défini par sa nature.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle
Dieu a amené
toutes les choses
en existence.
C'est par amour
pour nous permettre
de profiter
de son amour.
Mais c'est surtout
manifesté
dans l'évangile.
Dieu a tant aimé
les mondes
qu'il a donné
son fils unique.
Nous connaissons
cet amour
de Dieu,
nous expérimentons
cet amour
de Dieu,
Dieu qui allait bien
se prenne.
En étant
rempli d'amour,
nous pouvons
bien sûr
agir
de manière
amoureuse
envers les autres.
Et nous ne pouvons
pas agir
de manière
véritablement amoureuse
selon l'amour
de Dieu
envers les autres
si on n'a jamais
goûté
l'amour
de Dieu.
Car l'amour
inconditionnel
ou plutôt
contre-conditionnel
des dieux
envers nous,
c'est les combustibles
qui nous permettent
d'être
tellement remplis
qu'ils ont des
bords envers les autres.
Sinon,
l'amour humain
est tout simplement
les manquements,
la carence,
capricieux parfois
et très dépendant
de l'autre,
de ce que l'autre
peut fournir,
etc.
Ou sinon,
c'est idolâtre.
Quand je me donne
sans rien recevoir
et lorsque la personne
ne mérite même pas.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
l'amour des dieux
est quelque chose
qui m'a saisi,
m'a rempli
et qui déborde
envers les autres.
La joie,
c'est notamment
cet état
constant,
perpétuel,
qui est le résultat
direct
d'être satisfait
en Dieu.
Car toutes les choses
que Dieu a créées
nous donnent
en certain mesure
des plaisirs,
sauf que lui,
il est la source.
Il est la source
de tous les biens
et il est en soi
les biens suprêmes.
Donc,
les chrétiens sont décrits
lorsque Jésus
va prêcher l'évangile
à la fin de Samaritaine
comme ceux
qui ont bu
de cette eau
qui remplit
et déborde.
Donc,
c'est cette joie
qui doit marquer
les chrétiens.
Et,
on peut penser aussi
à la paix
comme en étant
la conscience
qui en ayant été
réconciliée
avec Dieu,
ayant été épargnée
de l'éternité
à l'enfer
qu'on méritait,
ayant été confrontée
par la plus grande
menace de notre âme
qui est véritablement
Dieu dans sa sainteté,
dans sa justice.
Il n'y a aucune autre
menace qu'on puisse
traverser dans cette vie
qui puisse nous faire peur
plus que la conscience
de nos péchés
devant Dieu Saint.
Et Dieu
qui nous a délivrés
de l'enfer
en assurant
une réconciliation telle
qu'il nous met déjà
dès aujourd'hui
dans cette assurance
d'être déjà assis
avec Christ
dans les lieux célestes,
c'est cette réconciliation
parfaite avec Dieu
qui m'émet
dans une position
d'être toujours
traité par Dieu,
comment père
traite ses enfants
et notre père
c'est celui
qui gouverne
tous les atomes
de l'univers.
Donc on peut être
devant une tempête,
un cyclone,
un tremblement
des terres,
on peut être devant
une maladie grave
et nous savons
qu'aucune de ces choses
n'auront jamais
la capacité
de nous priver
d'une éternité
des béatitudes
avec Dieu.
Et donc nous savons
une fois pour toutes
que la paix
du chrétien
elle est capable
de surmonter
les oscillations
des menaces
qui sont devant nous.
Donc c'est une condition,
un état d'esprit
qui est le résultat
de notre conversion.
Et quand on pense
aux trois prochaines vertus,
ce sont des vertus
qui sont presque
les débordements
de cet état d'esprit
dans nos relations
avec les autres.
Donc on voit la patience,
on voit la bénignité
et la bonté.
Donc c'est une patience
intentionnelle
car Dieu a été patient
envers moi,
j'essaierai patient
vers les autres.
Je sais que je ne peux
qu'attendre des personnes
qui ne sont pas nées de nouveau,
qui n'ont pas goûté
cet amour,
cette paix,
cette joie.
Je ne peux qu'attendre
de l'opposition
car c'était aussi
mon comportement
avant ma conversion.
Donc je supporte
les circonstances difficiles
et je supporte
l'opposition des personnes
envers qui
je marche patiemment
pour être
en train
de les bénir.
Et la bénignité,
c'est la résolution
d'être généreux
indépendamment
de ce que la personne
puisse mériter,
indépendamment
de ce que la personne
puisse avoir besoin.
Ce sont des choses
qu'on ne calcule pas
car ce sont des qualités
spirituelles.
C'est si je suis véritablement
une personne
qui a la vertu
de la bénignité,
je suis constamment
en train de chercher
à promouvoir
la vie des autres
sans trop consulter
quelle est la condition,
qu'est-ce qu'ils méritent,
quelle est la proportion,
etc.
Donc la bénignité suprême,
c'est de leur présenter
l'évangile,
la réconciliation
avec Dieu.
Donc je marche
patiemment,
je supporte tout
à cause des élus
comme dit l'apôtre Paul
afin de présenter
l'évangile.
Et donc la bénignité
et la patience,
elles sont quelque part
les manifestations
d'une bonté.
Cette bonté
est une bonté spirituelle,
c'est-à-dire
c'est une transformation
radicale
qui a eu lieu
dans nos vies
et nous ne pouvons
qu'être bénants
qu'être patients
car nous sommes bons
et nous étions
l'opposé du bon
avant la conversion.
Mais la conversion
opérait en nous
une nouvelle nature,
nous sommes nés pour Dieu,
nous sommes coparticipants
de la nature divine,
nous ne sommes pas parfaits
mais nous ne pouvons
même pas
ne pas être bénants
et patients
si nous avons été
véritablement transformés.
car Dieu est bon,
il agit de cette manière
envers nous.
Dieu,
lorsqu'il est en train
de pratiquer
sa bénignité envers nous
ou sa patience
envers nous,
quels sont les fondements
de la racine ?
L'explication publique,
ce n'est pas
car il a vu
qu'on aurait à avoir
les potentiels
pour être mieux
ou pour mériter
ou qu'on allait choisir
pour Dieu.
Ce n'est aucune chose
de ça.
C'est tout simplement
mais Dieu est un riche
en miséricorde
à cause de l'amour
avec lequel il vous a aimé.
Donc Dieu,
il n'a besoin qu'aider,
rentrer au-dedans
de l'humain
pour trouver
les motivations
pour nous aimer.
Donc la bénignité
des dieux
et la patience
des dieux envers nous
ne dépendent
d'aucune chose
en dehors des dieux.
Et de la même manière,
notre patience
et notre bénignité
envers les personnes
ne peuvent dépendre
d'aucune chose autre
qu'à notre bonté
en dieux.
C'est compris ?
Et nous arrivons
aux trois dernières
vertus.
et nous avons
la fidélité,
la douceur
et la tempérance.
On a vu
la semaine dernière
la douceur
et la fidélité.
Et ce qui est intéressant
par rapport
à ces trois derniers,
c'est que ce sont eux
qui vont assurer
quelque part
la constance
de ces fruits.
Ce sont eux
qui vont assurer
par exemple
que peu importe
si on est
au Brésil
ou en France,
une pomme
sera une pomme.
Et donc,
qu'est-ce qui va
assurer
la constance
de ces fruits ?
Ce qui assure
la constance
de ces fruits,
c'est ce qu'on peut
appeler
la fiabilité
des fruits.
Si j'ai goût
de ces fruits,
peu importe
qu'ils soient,
en quelles circonstances
ils se trouvent,
il aura les goûts
on va dire
des dieux.
Il aura les goûts
du Christ.
Peu importe
si je trouve
une pomme
sur la tempête,
sur la pluie
ou dans un beau jour,
elle aura les goûts
des pommes.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et donc,
c'est très important
de considérer
que ces trois éléments,
ils ont
ces points de commun,
c'est-à-dire
la constance.
Et ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que quand on pense
à la fidélité
ou la foi
dans la racine du mot,
c'est quelque part
dans le sens
où je serai fidèle
à la proportion
quelque part
de ma foi.
Et ma foi,
à nouveau,
ce n'est pas mon effort
de croire plus
ou moins,
ce n'est pas la taille
de ma foi en soi,
mais c'est notamment
la taille
de ma perspective,
de mon intimité
avec les vrais dieux.
on peut
parfois douter
de notre salut
étant véritablement sauvé.
Les doutes
envers
mon assurance
de salut
ne changent en rien
l'assurance
en soi
de mon salut,
car l'assurance
de mon salut
ne dépend pas
de la force
de ma foi,
elle dépend
de la taille
de mon Dieu,
elle dépend
de l'œuvre
parfaite du Christ.
Donc la plupart
d'Israël
étaient en train
de se corrompre,
d'affaiblir,
de négocier,
de faire des jeux politiques
quand ils sont en train
de voir la grande menace
de cette culture
ou de ces gérants
qui étaient
Goliath.
Sauf que David,
dans sa perspective
des choses,
il avait tellement
plus d'intimité
avec Dieu,
il avait beaucoup
plus d'intimité
avec la perspective
d'un Dieu grand
qui fait son œuvre,
qui fait avancer
son œuvre
et donc il ne se sent
pas tenté
à se corrompre
avec la majorité,
ou à négocier
les choses
avec la culture,
à changer la manière
par exemple
de faire l'église
pour chercher
à attirer
plus de personnes.
S'il est
convaincu
de la capacité
du Christ,
de la taille
du Christ
pour sauver,
des moyens
que Christ utilise
pour sauver,
il sera fidèle.
Vous voyez
la relation
entre foi,
c'est-à-dire
la confiance
que je dépose
en Dieu
à ses manières,
à ses moyens
et la manière
dont je vis ma vie.
Une vie
marquée par la fidélité,
c'est une vie
qui est proportionnelle
à une intimité
avec la capacité
des dieux,
d'être fidèle
à sa parole,
à ses promesses,
d'être tout puissant
pour assurer
que ses moyens
sont les moyens
qui vont marcher.
Et donc,
quand on pense
à la fidélité
qu'ils devront pratiquer,
elles sont aussi liées
à cette notion
d'allégeance.
C'est-à-dire,
c'est en sens
de dévoi.
Si j'ai véritablement
compris l'évangile,
si j'ai véritablement
expérimenté
la transformation
pourvue par l'évangile
dans ma vie
et si je contemple
la fidélité des dieux,
lorsque je regarde
la manière
dont je vais vivre,
je serai fidèle
par une question
des devoirs.
Et quand je suis
véritablement
en train de craindre
plus Dieu
que toutes les choses
autour de moi
et quand je plague
mon allégeance
envers Dieu
au-dessus de toute autre
allégeance
que je puisse avoir
dans cette vie,
je serai fiable.
Lorsqu'un chrétien
ne marche pas
de manière fiable
comme un fruit,
lorsqu'il ne se porte pas
avec la symétrie
et l'harmonie
de ses caractères
qui nous est présenté ici,
nous vivrons
à la proportion
de cette vie
symétriquement
parfaite
équilibrée
du Christ
selon
la fidélité
à cet évangile
qui nous a touchés.
Et donc,
notre sens de devoir
c'est
même si parfois
ma volonté
c'est d'agir différemment,
même si je suis
sous pression,
je serai
fidèle.
Je ne vais pas
craquer sous pression,
je serai
fidèle.
Et cette résolution
d'être fidèle
par la constance
de la pratique
augmente la foi
et en même temps
elle assure
ses goûts constants.
Et donc,
quand on est en train
de voir
un chrétien
très oscillant
dans sa fidélité,
dans sa fiabilité,
en général,
nous pouvons voir
un chrétien
qui est un constant
dans son intimité
avec Christ,
qui est un constant
dans cette relation
fondamentale
avec Christ,
la taille du Christ
pour elle
est petite.
Mais c'est
ses sens de devoir
qui marquent
la fidélité.
La douceur,
elle va plutôt
être marquée
par les termes
dans l'original,
il a à voir
avec une volonté
domptée.
C'est comme
un cheval
qui est adouci
ou qui est
apprivoisé
quelque part.
Et donc,
quelque part,
cette douceur,
elle va
naturellement
assurer
les goûts aussi,
la fiabilité
du goût,
non des manières
tout simplement
à considérer
l'aspect
des devoirs.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Oui.
Mais c'est une
soumission volontaire.
Ce sont des chevaux,
on va dire comme ça,
que nous pouvons
nous considérer
avec beaucoup
de force,
mais qui
soumettons
notre force
à un moment donné
à la manière
du Christ
de nous conduire,
à la manière
du Saint-Esprit
de nous guider.
Et c'est volontaire,
car dans les passages
bibliques qui parlent
de la douceur,
c'est cette humiliation
qu'on a tous
expérimenté
si on est
véritablement converti,
tout ce qui était
opposé à Christ.
On peut imaginer
l'apôtre Paul,
par exemple,
qui marchait
en persécution
contre l'Église
et Christ
qui va apparaître
devant lui
avec cette
attirance
glorieuse
et avec cette
présence
quelque part
grave,
toute puissante,
l'éclat
des lumières.
Et là,
la volonté
de l'apôtre Paul,
les ailes fanatiques
de l'apôtre Paul
sont complètement
apprivoisés.
Et désormais,
il va volontairement
soumettre sa vie
à la manière
d'écrire
et de le diriger.
C'est comme ça
qu'il nous a décrit
cette réalité
en Galate chapitre 2
lorsqu'il dit
« J'ai été crucifié
avec Christ
et si j'ai vu,
ce n'est plus moi
qui vis,
c'est Christ
qui vit en moi
et si j'ai vu
maintenant dans la chair,
j'ai vu dans la foi
au Fils de Dieu
qui m'a aimé
et qui s'est livré
lui-même pour moi. »
Donc là,
on voit de manière
très belle
et très glorieuse
de quelle manière
Paul a été adouci.
Paul qui n'a pas perdu
ses capacités,
qui n'a jamais perdu
son hardiesse,
sa fermeté,
mais qui a soumis
ses volontés
constamment
à la gouvernance
du Christ
et de son esprit.
Donc,
quand on est confronté
par les personnes
qui veulent opposer
l'amour
qu'on vise
à manifester
envers eux,
quand on est défié
par les persécutions,
par l'ingratitude
et peu importe
quelles soient
les raisons
qui ont la tendance
à provoquer en nous
de la colère
et un traitement
qui manque
de douceur,
nous devons nous rappeler
que Dieu
et Christ
ils avaient
tous les droits
d'être en colère
contre nous,
de manifester
sa juste indignation
contre nous,
de nous punir
et de nous lancer
dans l'enfer,
mais Dieu,
il agit de manière
douce.
Le Christ lui-même
s'est présent
comme étant
doux et humble
de cœur.
Et donc,
ça a beaucoup
à voir,
cette douceur,
avec avoir développé
un cœur enseignable
et tous ceux
qui ont appris
à développer
un cœur enseignable
ont appris
à propos
de leur humilité,
ont souffert
cette humiliation
à propos
de sa pauvreté
spirituelle.
Ils ont tous appris
qu'ils n'ont rien
à réclamer par droit,
qu'ils n'ont
aucune chose
à défendre
car nous sommes
tous
peubres en esprit
et donc,
on a désisté
de l'autre promotion
et de l'autre protection.
Ce qui importe,
ce qui importe
pour nous,
c'est Christ
est celui-ci crucifié,
proclamé aux gentils
pour leur salaire.
Et donc,
c'est cette douceur
qui va assurer
car à chaque fois
qu'on revoit
les œuvres
de la chair
et à chaque fois
qu'on voit surtout
ces œuvres
de la chair
qui nous poussent
à la division,
aux disputes,
à l'animosité,
c'est particulièrement
cette douceur
qui doit
assurer
la constance
de notre comportement
avec amour,
avec joie,
avec paix,
avec patience,
bénignité,
bonté
car nous avons appris
à agir
de manière gentille,
agir de manière douce
envers les autres
car Christ
nous a apprivoisés.
C'est comme Paul a dit,
c'est volontaire.
Je peux tout supporter
à cause des élus
ou lorsqu'il dit
qu'il est en train
de souffrir
pour les salaires
des autres,
il va dire
car l'amour du Christ
il est constant.
Ok ?
Et donc c'est Paul
dans sa dynamique.
Et quand on considère
notamment la tempérance,
qui est le dernier,
ces éléments,
nous voyons de manière
très puissante
quelque chose
qui peut être considéré,
je dirais comme
la manière la plus
immédiate
d'assurer
l'ensemble
du fruit.
Donc on sait
que chacun
de ses vertus
sont
fruits de l'esprit
et donc
en vertu spirituelle,
une qualité
produite par l'esprit
et donc on n'est jamais
dans la dynamique
tout simplement du faire.
Par contre,
il y a la dynamique
de la coopération,
de la manifestation
consciente,
de la résolution
à agir
de cette manière.
Et la tempérance
quelque part,
c'est celle
qui va assurer
cette constance
de tous les éléments.
Pourquoi ?
Car chez l'individu
chrétien,
la tempérance,
elle est la manière
la plus immédiate,
la plus authentique
de recevoir
cette exhortation
et de la mettre
en pratique.
C'est-à-dire,
nous serons tous
défiés
constamment
par les tentations
et par les circonstances
à ne pas manifester
les fruits,
l'amour,
la joie,
la paix,
la patience,
etc.
Quelle sera
la réaction
la plus immédiate ?
Et si nous voulons
cultiver les fruits
de manière positive,
c'est par la tempérance
que nous allons
cultiver ça aussi,
par la diligence.
Donc,
si Paul laisse
pour la fin
la tempérance,
bien sûr,
qui a un rapport
avec la liste
des eaux de la chair,
on va réveiller bientôt,
mais c'est aussi lié
au fait que
en finissant
avec la conscience
et la tempérance
comme une qualité
que le Saint-Esprit
produit en nous,
nous soyons tous
engagés
à être
diligents
dans l'exercice
et la maîtrise
de nous-mêmes
pour assurer
les goûts de fruits,
pour être plus clair.
la manière
dont je vis
quand personne
ne me voit
révèle
l'authenticité
de ma diligence,
de mon intimité,
de mon désir profond
d'être clair,
mon Seigneur.
Quand personne
ne me voit,
car parfois
c'est même facile
d'assumer
des responsabilités
au sein de l'Église,
dans un service,
et cette motivation
de tenir bon,
de tenir ferme
devant les personnes
peut m'aider
quelque part
à me maîtriser
un peu plus.
sauf que la vraie
maîtrise de soi,
la vraie
tempérance,
elle a lieu
lorsqu'il ne me voit.
C'est comme les puritans
qui étaient persécutés,
identifiés
comme puritans.
Quand on voyait,
lorsqu'ils étaient en train
de polir
les bancs
qu'ils produisaient,
les sièges,
je ne sais pas
comment dire
en français exactement,
les chaises,
là où personne
ne les voyait,
c'était que les puritans
qui polissaient
cette partie-là.
Et comme ça,
ils étaient identifiés.
Pourquoi ?
Car ils faisaient
toutes les choses
pour la gloire des gens.
Je ne suis pas
en train de ramasser
un bout de papier
par terre,
tout simplement
car quelqu'un
en train de regarder.
même lorsque personne
n'est en train de regarder,
je vais faire
ces moindres choses
car je sais
que mon Seigneur
est en train de regarder.
Et en général,
les personnes
qui ne sont pas fiables
lorsqu'elles sont
toutes seules
avec Dieu
dans les moindres choses
ne seront pas fiables
dans les choses
plus importantes.
Vous avez été fidèles
dans les peuples,
je vous confie
beaucoup plus.
donc la vraie tempérance,
elle est quelque part
la manière la plus immédiate
d'assurer les touts.
car si je suis
en train de réagir
autrement
que par la manifestation
du fruit,
c'est comme si j'étais
en train d'oublier
que mon Seigneur
à qui j'ai déclaré
mon amour
n'est pas en train
de participer
de ces moments spécifiques
de ma vie.
Par contre,
si ma relation
et mon intimité
avec Christ
est véritablement
la chose la plus importante
de ma vie,
à chaque instant
je serai en train
de me circonscrire
et constreindre
être conscient
de ma prochaine action
ou réaction
pour plaire
mon Seigneur
avec qui je suis associé
depuis
la racine
de mon être.
Vous comprenez
l'importance
de la tempérance ?
Donc la tempérance
n'est pas
de vivre une vie
hyper diligente.
et bien sûr
qu'elle va s'exprimer
par l'ordre.
Par quelque part
l'autoprotection
constante
contre la chair,
la structure
d'une vie
qui se protège
des tentations
constamment
et par une vie
ordonnée
pour cultiver constamment
cette relation
avec l'esprit.
C'est clair ?
Donc en général
une personne
qui a la tempérance
elle a cette tempérance
qui se manifeste
de manière générale
par une vie
ordonnée.
Par contre
ce n'est pas
une vie
ordonnée
par un
checklist.
Ce n'est pas
une espèce
de discipline
fragmentée.
Certains
aires de ma vie
je suis hyper
discipliné
et j'ai conquis
les stigmes
d'être une personne
réputée
par discipliné.
Parfois
je suis hyper
discipliné
à mon travail
par contre
dans ma relation
avec mon épouse
ou envers
mes enfants
c'est un bazar.
Ce n'est pas
superficiel
motivé
par l'orgueil
qui veut
se manifester
par apparence
de manière utilitaire.
Ce n'est pas
très méthodique
ni mécanique.
C'est une tempérance
où Jésus
j'aime bien
ces passages
il est sollicité
pour aller
guérir un enfant
qui était en train
de mourir
mais au milieu
du chemin
il y a cette femme
qui souffre
à 14 ans
et qui l'arrête.
Deux sollicitations
et peut-être
qui n'ont
des priorités
légitimes
mais il va
s'arrêter
et pour plus
ordonner
que ce soit
sa vie
il n'aura pas
une relation
envers l'ordre
de la vie
ou les priorités
de manière
à négliger
les opportunités
qui apparaissent
pour servir
un peu plus.
pour faire un peu plus
pour se sacrifier
un peu plus.
La tempérance
c'est une ordre
des priorités
qui se porte
vers la piété
l'objectif
de la relation
avec Dieu
et pas
la discipline
des pharisiens
qui pouvaient
checker
toutes les listes
des comportements
d'habillement
mais qui étaient
en train
de négliger
des choses
moins visibles
qui étaient
beaucoup plus
importantes
en termes
des compassions
des miséricordes
et des sacrifices
pour promouvoir
les biens des autres.
Et donc
parfois
il y a
une capacité
très méthodique
pour
contrôler
les comportements
mais qui empêche
les pharisiens
de guérir
dans un sabbat.
C'est important
car si nous vivons
authentiquement
notre relation
avec Christ
la tempérance
ne nous conduira
pas
à une abstinence
aveugle
sans sens.
L'apôtre Paul
va dire même
que ce sont
des doctrines
des démons
des personnes
qui veulent proposer
que la vie
sante
c'est
de s'abstérir
complètement
des bonnes choses
que Dieu a créées
et de même
pas se marier
pour donner l'impression
d'être plus sante
que les autres.
Mais des fois
ma tempérance
vécue avec Dieu
me permettra
d'avoir
quelques plaisirs
dans cette vie
même lorsqu'il y a
un pharisiens
qui cherche
à observer ma vie
et qui veut
noter
tous mes manquements
dans les détails
pourrait
m'efforcer
parfois
à m'empêcher
de faire certaines choses
et en même temps
la tempérance
elle me conduit
aussi
à ne pas
réjouir
de certaines choses
que j'ai
doigts
que j'ai la paix
pour réjouir
pour ne pas servir
de scandale
à un autre.
Et tout cela
dépend d'une tempérance
authentique
qui ne peut pas
être calculée
par une machine
calculatrice.
Cette tempérance
elle est surtout
vécue par Christ
comme nous voyons
de manière très belle
et très glorieuse
dans plusieurs passages
en Christ
qui a été
en tout tenté
toutefois sans péché
qui peut être
pour nous
les modèles
suprêmes
de tempérance
celui qui n'avait pas
vécu une abstinence
totale
par exemple du vent
mais qui n'a jamais
goûté
une seule goutte
en plus
de ce qui était
légitime
et sans
qui était parfois
trouvé dans des faits
considéré comme celui
qui était avec
ceux qui mangent
beaucoup
ou boivent beaucoup
mais qu'en même temps
n'a jamais mangé
un peu plus
que ce qui serait
sans et parfait
tempérance
équilibre
réjouissance
c'est lui
qui était accusé
parfois
de marcher
avec les pécheurs
mais qui était
avec eux
pour les quitter
de cette vie
péchéresse
et donc
cet équilibre
parfait du Christ
qui connaissait
très bien
sa toute puissance
et qui marche
vers la croix
en sachant
que lorsque
Pierre
tire son épée
pour couper
l'oreille
de ses gardes
de ses gardiens
les Christ
va les réprocher
il va rappeler
Pierre
j'aurais pu appeler
les anges
de myriades
des anges
qu'on va les livrer
et donc
au lieu
d'agir
autrement
qu'avec
la douceur
il maîtrise
cette force
et Dieu
les pères
qui à la croix
est en train
de maîtriser
cette colère
il y a plein de passages
je n'aurai pas
le temps
de citer
dans l'ancien testament
pour manifester
Dieu
dans sa fidélité
lorsqu'il dit à Israël
ce n'est pas à cause
du fait que vous êtes
un peu plus nombreux
ou car vous êtes
très important
mais c'est à cause
de ma fidélité
que je suis en train
de faire ces choses
et ensuite
parfois
lorsqu'Israël
est en train
de provoquer
sa colère
il dit
je vais agir
comme mon père
car je suis
un père
compatissant
je n'agirai pas
à la proportion
de ce que vous méritez
et cette tempérance
cette douceur
d'un père
qui dit
je vous porterai
comme des brébis
dans ma poitrine
quelle douceur
et à la croix
un Dieu
qui est en train
de manière
vraiment
très chirurgicale
il est en train
de dévier
la joue scolaire
qui devrait
retrouver sur nous
envers soi-même
dans la personne
de son fils
bien-aimé
en démontrant
une maîtrise
de soi
qui a été
précise
pour notre rédemption
un Christ
qui n'était pas
tout simplement
la victime
c'est un Christ
qui s'élivre
lui-même
c'est Christ
qui a venu
une première fois
comme une brébine
doux
et humble
de coeur
et qui reviendra
comme un lion
et donc
si nous sommes exposés
si nous avons
expérimenté
la réalité
de cette foi
d'un Dieu
qui nous a traités
par ses caractères
parfaits
symétriques
un Dieu
qui habite en nous
par son esprit
nous avons dû
déjà
expérimenter
de manière radicale
ses vertus
et au fur et à mesure
que nous nous plongeons
dans la considération
du fruit
de l'esprit
nous devons
résoudre
de les manifester
tout simplement
vous voyez l'optimisme
biblique
et quand on s'approche
de la conclusion
de ces passages
en ayant considéré
cette tempérance
l'apôtre Paul
va dire le suivant
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
donc ici
nous avons
les trois groupes
que Paul
cherche à corriger
les judaïsants
d'un côté
qui voulaient
baser leur réaction
avec Dieu
encore par la performance
une idée
restaurée
d'un Dieu
contre nous
et on essaye
de reconquérir
l'amour de Dieu
d'un autre côté
ceux qui disent
donc Christ a tout fait déjà
donc je peux me plonger
dans les péchés
car il a tout payé
utiliser de la liberté
pour donner occasion
à ma chair
et l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de corriger
ces deux mauvaises
conceptions
les fruits
que les saints esprits
produisent
est suffisant
pour qu'il y ait
des manières
naturelles
réconciliées
avec Christ
nous vivons
une vie telle
c'est à dire
les fruits de l'esprit
cette vie d'amour
cette vie symétrique
c'est impossible
de ne pas
être en train
d'accomplir
la loi
même si je ne connais
aucun détail
à propos de la loi
vivre cette vie
dans l'esprit
manifester constamment
ses fruits
c'est de ne pas
trouver des limites
aucune restriction
ne peut être présentée
devant ses caractères
ses vertus
voici
comme Christ a vécu
comme Christ vit
voici la vie
de Dieu
la loi
n'existe pas
devant
l'amour
la pureté
positive
de cette vie
glorieuse
que Dieu vit
cette douceur
cette symétrie
parfaite
cette tempérance
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
donc les légalistes
ne peuvent
jamais
chercher
à imposer
des limites
ou donner
des lois
qui puissent
servir
des moyens
plus élevés
que l'influence
de son esprit
lui-même
à nouveau
la loi
a été complètement
rejetée
pour nous
pas du tout
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
c'est à dire
si nous sommes
en train de vivre
dans l'esprit
nous sommes
en train de marcher
non sous la loi
!
mais nous sommes en train de marcher
sur la loi
elle sert pour nous
comme les rails
d'entrée
mais nous vivons
dans l'esprit
et nous marchons
dans la bonne direction
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
c'est fini
le légalisme
en même temps
elle est
très efficace
contre les oeuvres
de la chair
donc
si nous vivons
dans l'esprit
ça
il avait déjà prouvé
nous sommes en train
de nous opposer
à cette vie
qui était marquée
par la chair
donc je ne peux pas
dire
que ça tout fait
donc je mets
plonger les péchés
vous voyez
comme Paul
est en train
de manifester
et la tempérance
elle est quelque part
non seulement
celle qui est
la plus capable
de se confronter
au comportement
plus bestial
l'immoralité sexuelle
du début de la liste
ou par exemple
la gloutonnerie
et les entorpeçons
du fond de la liste
des oeuvres de la chair
bien sûr
qu'elle est là aussi
pour la tempérance
mais même
pour les autres
donc pensons
par exemple
aujourd'hui
à cet aspect
des pharmakés
et je pense
c'est important
de revenir
car dans la culture
française
c'est important
nous sommes
les plus grands
consommateurs
des psychotropes
au monde
c'est-à-dire
faire recours
à la médecine
parfois
ou la pseudo-médecine
pour chercher
à régler des choses
que la tempérance
serait beaucoup plus
efficace
à régler
une tendance
à nous victimiser
à accepter
n'importe quel type
de diagnostic
par rapport
à notre comportement
et traiter
certaines choses
qui dans cette liste
sont traitées
comme péché
et nous voulons
les traiter
plutôt comme
désordre
ou maladie
mais c'est impossible
en considérant
la satisfaction
des lames
chrétiennes
qui débordent
envers
patience
bonté
bénéguilité
c'est dur
de trouver
un espace
dans la description
du chrétien
dans la Bible
pour un diagnostic
des bipolarités
c'est pas pour dire
que c'est impossible
mais on ne trouve pas
beaucoup d'espace
pour la syndrome
endoponique
crise d'anxiété
soit on n'a pas
bien compris
l'évangile
soit on est
très en dissonance
avec l'évangile
mais chercher
les raccourcis
à cause
de notre manque
de tempérance
manque
de maîtrise
de nous-mêmes
de lieu de réagir
comme l'audi
disait
les chrétiens
c'est lui
qui dit quoi
aux tentations
quoi moi
fils de Dieu
c'est lui
qui a été
capacité
par l'esprit
pour agir
avec douceur
mais mettre
en colère
devant cette situation
c'est lui
qui a connu
l'amour
d'alliance
du Christ
mon mari parfait
tombé
dans cette tentation
si rébaissé
des porneias
et quand on se trouve
devant les
pharmakèles
qu'on a déjà
considéré
on doit être
beaucoup plus
judicieux
avant d'embrasser
tout diagnostic
est-ce que
ce n'est pas
très intéressant
pour ma chair
au lieu
de traiter
mes manquements
mon manque
de maîtrise
de moi
au lieu
de chercher
par les médicaments
réelle
de la tempérance
si le Saint-Esprit
habite en nous
si nous nous
considérons
chrétiens
la force
la plus efficace
pour lutter
contre ces choses
se trouvent ici
pour ceux
qui sont nés
de nouveau
bien sûr
que ceux
qui ne sont pas
encore nés
de nouveau
doivent faire
recours
à la deuxième option
qui est
bien loin
une distance
infinie
comme un palliatif
et la réalité
c'est qu'il n'y a pas
comment régler
les problèmes
de tout désordre humain
de toute manifestation
des œuvres
de la chair
si ce n'est pas
par la conversion
et par la présence
de son esprit
chez nous
voilà pourquoi
l'apôtre Paul dit
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
et ensuite
il va dire
deux phrases
très importantes
de ces 24 et 25
ceux qui sont
à Jésus Christ
ont crucifié
la chair
avec ses passions
et désirs
donc là
on est devant
la crucifixion
c'est un indigatif
d'un côté
qui sert aussi
d'exhortation
implicite
c'est une description
si vous êtes
véritablement chrétien
cela veut dire
soyez avec moi
je vais finir bientôt
cela veut dire
que
lorsque Christ
est allé
à la croix
en portant
votre nom
spécifique
sur sa patrie
comme un suprême
sacrificateur
car tous ceux
qui sont
réconciliés
avec Dieu
par Christ
ce sont ceux
que Christ
a représentés
devant ses tribunales
cosmiques
à la croix
à notre place
lorsqu'il Christ
était en train
de crucifier
sa chair
n'était pas
contaminée
par les péchés
mais il était
en train
de crucifier
notre chair
cette association
était réelle
Christ n'était pas
en train
de tenter
quelque chose
à la croix
il était en train
de faire quelque chose
de manière efficace
il a été victorieux
à la croix
et s'il me représentait
dans cette croix
il était en train
de crucifier
de donner
un coup mortel
dans ma chair
avec ses passions
et ses désirs
ce n'est pas du tout
de l'hypocrisie
de nous dire
mais si j'ai dit
non à cette tentation
je ne suis pas honnête
avec ma volonté
pas du tout
ça c'est
le reste
de notre volonté
rébelle
corrompue
mais il y a
une nouvelle volonté
chez les chrétiens
qui prédomine
la volonté
de se sanctifier
et donc
quelle est
l'exhortation
implicite
tout comme Christ
a crucifié
ma chair
dans sa mort
lorsque j'ai déposé
ma foi en lui
ma compréhension
réelle
de l'évangile
c'était de dire
je veux m'associer
avec lui
en crucifiant
ma chair
c'est plus moi
qui vis
je suis mort
pour moi-même
vous êtes avec moi
et j'ai expérimenté
la réalité
au moins
dans la période
fraîche
de ma conversion
j'ai expérimenté
la réalité
d'avoir été
affranchi
de l'esclavage
de la chair
c'est comme si
la chair
avait perdu
de manière
très profonde
sa puissance
elle a souffert
un coup mortel
et je peux
constater
dans ma vie
au moins
de ma conversion
combien j'étais
beaucoup plus
victorieux
contre la chair
et donc
ma résolution
l'exhortation
les rappels
de l'apôtre
vous avez déjà
vécu ça
accepté
ça
donc
reprenez
cette attitude
envers la chair
bataille
violence
contre la chair
douceur
envers les persécuteurs
vers tout ce qui
est autour de vous
violence
contre vous-même
comme par les excuses
de zèle
mais Christ
il était indigné
au temple
ok
ayez l'équilibre
si c'est une exception
au moment très ponctuel
de manifester
cette juste indignation
vous pouvez le faire
mais demandez-vous
si dans votre constance
vous n'êtes plus marqué
par la douceur
crucifier constamment
la chair
à chaque fois
que la chair
frappe à la porte
la faire mourir
des femmes
ok
d'empêlance
et de l'autre côté
et c'est 25
si nous vivons
par l'esprit
marchons
aussi selon l'esprit
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
c'est pas une condition
si nous vivons
par l'esprit
c'est
à nouveau
un indicatif
c'est une description
ok
vu que
dès que
nous vivons par l'esprit
comme vous
avez expérimenté
une nouvelle naissance
par l'esprit
car par la chair
vous étiez esclave
de vos passions
passion
à partir du moment
où le saint-esprit
vous a régénéré
a fait de vous
une nouvelle nature
comme vous êtes
vivant
par l'esprit
comme c'est le saint-esprit
qui vous a fait
naître
de nouveau
comme vous ne pouvez pas
vivre par la loi
!
ni par vos efforts
si dans votre extérieur
des conversions
vous savez reconnaître
que vous avez été
peut-être comme moi
exposé à l'évangile
à plusieurs reprises
sans se convertir
mais à un moment donné
les écailles des yeux
sont tombées
et vous ne pouvez
qu'attribuer
votre conversion
au fait
que le saint-esprit
nous a fait
comprendre l'évangile
de manière salvatrice
en nous unissant
le saint-esprit lui-même
à Christ
et à son oeuvre
si vous êtes conscient
que le saint-esprit
agit en vous
habite en vous
si c'est à lui
que vous attribuez
cette relation nouvelle
avec Dieu
où vous voyez
Dieu comme un père
c'est saint-esprit
qui exerce
son influence en nous
pour nous convaincre
que nous sommes
enfants de Dieu
et que nous pouvons dire
Abba Père envers Dieu
si vous avez déjà
expérimenté
cette résurrection
spirituelle
nouvelle vie
donc
si vous avez été
amené à la vie
par l'esprit
suivez
les pas
du saint-esprit
qu'est-ce qu'il est
en train de dire ici
si vous
créditez au saint-esprit
votre nouvelle naissance
confiez vos vies
dans la pratique
au saint-esprit
dans sa manière
de vous conduire
envers
la sanctification
ne soyez pas
qui est satisfait
avec
beaucoup de progrès
que vous avez eu peut-être
entre votre vie
prégrès
et la renaissance
mais continuez
à maintenir
les pas
du saint-esprit
les rythmes
dans l'original
la notion
c'est
ce sont ceux
qui marchent
comme dans
une queue
où le saint-esprit
va dicter
les pas
et nous allons
suivre ces pas
et ça peut s'appliquer
dans toutes les airs
mais
la notion ici
c'est
c'est Christ
formé en vous
c'est les fruits
de l'esprit
formés en vous
et il veut
que ces vertus
soient manifestées
progressivement
chaque fois plus
et que vos vies
soient consacrées
à ces choses
et c'est pas
de se donner
à moitié
envers la direction
que le saint-esprit
vous donne
c'est
si vous êtes
résolu
à maintenir
ces pas
avec le saint-esprit
vous allez
progresser
vous voyez
crucifier la chair
c'est une partie
du travail
vigilant
envers la chair
violence
contre la chair
mais
les plus positives
de cette exhortation
c'est
je vais marcher
dans l'esprit